you have been in both the supporter and
a critic of competition what do you
think is the value of competition for
martial artists I believe that the value
of competition is in that it teaches you
the true purpose of martial arts and in
ending and the true purpose of martial
arts is being able to defend yourself
and whatnot in all of these other things
in real life yes because you let's say
you win a DCCC gold medal but you know
you get slapped around by someone bigger
and stronger you at a bar that people
will talk about how sweet that gold
medal is but for the rest of your life
it'll feel pretty Hollow that wouldn't
you know that's not what we're looking
for but what I'm talking about I guess
is what I believe competition develops
if approached properly is proper focused
proper dedication because anytime you
have a very defined goal and strong
opposition it will force you to be
better period the better your opposition
is if you focus and you take your what
you're doing seriously the better you
become period people are better
wrestlers today than they once were
people are better basketball players
today than they once were military is
better now that it was in the past
because of all of the competition
that you know that is existed over the
course of time and you know if you go
out competition if you go out and just
kind of [ __ ] it if you're like oh
I'm going to go out and see how it
happens like that's a cowardly way to
approach competition and that gets you
nothing that doesn't teach you to really
do the right things and the same thing
not for pot not properly preparing even
if you win that was a cowardly way to
approach it because you intentionally
left yourself an out which was if I win
man I'm talented in blah-dee-blah and if
I lose it's well you know I mean I could
I didn't really train that hard well if
that's the case then you shouldn't have
been out there win lose or draw I don't
care if I've got a student that I think
is going to win gold at the World
Championships he or she does not train
properly ahead of time I will not allow
them to go and if they go I will send
them off the team you know and hey they
can do what they want they're a grown
adult I'm not the boss of them but I am
the boss of my team it wasn't my gym and
that's not how we conduct ourselves and
it has way less to do about the physical
you know the result and it does about
the proper preparation is proper
preparation and proper focus and
dedication over the long haul yields
positive results but most importantly
it's about are we conducting ourselves
in a in an honorable and respectable
manner so I believe that the competition
really teaches us that because in the
room you know there's always like oh it
was practice so I was kind of this -
that happened today the other thing when
you go to competition everyone is that's
on everyone is on that day because
everyone is trained
for that specific moment and we'll see
what happens so you get the most honesty
out of it out of a time like that and
the higher the level the better it gets
in you know provided that there's not a
lot of cheating but regardless you know
from an athletic performance perspective
it is the most honest thing because and
it's the it's the toughest as well
because it takes it takes courage and it
takes some heart to really properly
prepare and put it on the line because
you're risking horrible disappointment
I've prepared so hard before and tried
so hard and I've won and I've prepared
other times and I've tried so hard and
I've failed and it hurts it really hurts
it doesn't hurt nearly as much if you
kind of half-ass it because you didn't
put that much into it but again that's
how a coward approaches things if you
have if you're going to conduct yourself
the right way you prepare properly you
train hard and then win lose or draw you
deal with the results and that's what I
believe is the real benefit of
competition if approached properly do
you admire somebody who sacrifices you
know like 10 20 years of their life in
that singular pursuit of competition
towards a gold medal at the Olympics a
almost of the Olympians do goodness
absolutely I mean I admire anyone that's
willing to sacrifice and willing to work
hard in any area of life actually a book
that I'm reading again that I really
really like is dune it's a I'm kind of
like sci-fi nerd hangout on everybody
but basically a you know one of the
things that you know one of the one of
the you know things that the the author
was going to Frank Herbert and it's why
the regarded is one of the you know
greatest science fiction novels ever if
not the preeminent but anyway well the
things you said you know is if you if
you search for freedom you actually end
up becoming a slave to your own desires
ironically and if you search for
discipline you find liberty because
you're able to make yourself do what you
want in the long run whereas if I'm like
oh I'm going to do whatever I want all
the time and screw you dead I'm going to
do what I want that's kind of like a
teenager type attitude you end up
getting into a bunch of nonsense but
anyone that's able and again this
doesn't matter it doesn't mean that it's
athletic it could be in any area of
human endeavor any area of life it could
be parenting it could be military it
could be athletics to be business it
could be school to be anything but as
long as you're making you know an
incredibly large commitment I have an
immense amount of respect for the for
the level of dedication that and the
level of commitment and a level of
risk that it that you're taking
emotionally psychologically because hey
like you said you work twenty years you
get that gold medal but there's other
people that work twenty years and got
the silver most people know the medal
now most people most people that think
they work hard don't I'll be frank
you know like seriously I said that in
class the other day like again it's like
I don't want to be too negative but most
the people that most people to think
they work hard do not how do you know
that if you're working hard or not I
think you know but most people are not
very honest with themselves they were
most people would press a button in my
experience you know they would prefer to
be look like the thing and then be the
thing and you know that's that's fine
but it really I can't I think Sun Tzu
said it's a victory is reserved for
those willing to pay its price and there
is a price and now that doesn't
guarantee that if you pay the price that
you will have victory but you guarantee
but I mean from a physical perspective
but you will have the moral victory
regardless because you will have you
will have learned discipline you'll have
shown not only to others forget others
you do it not for others but for
yourself you you show that you are the
master of your own mind and of your own
body and of your own circumstance and
you can discipline yourself and focus
and you deny yourself certain things in
the pursuit of something something that
is valuable to you and that is
incredibly useful in any area of life
and that's not mean not shocking to me
why the same reason that you'll see guys
that were you know like high-level
military like kind of big dogs on SF
world get hired by let's say for
instance a fortune 500 company because
what would they know about business
nothing but also everything because that
level of focus and dedicate like you
don't get to that level of ability in
something by accident and that's what I
think you know like again the value of
competition and what they do competition
only it's as serious as it gets you know
because if you don't get the gold medal
it you may not you may not walk out of
it but basically I have an immense
amount of respect for anyone that is
willing and able to over the long haul
put that time in but I have to trying
hard doesn't mean just getting on an air
Don bike and walking off the mat or
having to be carried off the mat it
means thinking approaching reassessing
reevaluating saying how could I be
better and it takes honest on a
self-analysis and
and also it takes a lot of times because
let's say you know I think I'm doing
well but I got to say hey Lex you know I
mean no matter how how well I believe I
look at myself I'm still biased I'm
still looking at myself what should I be
doing better I'm gonna find other people
that I respect and people that I think
can tell me and I'm gonna ask them and
then I'm gonna have the courage to
listen to them and not just dismiss what
they're saying out of hand and if you're
doing those things then I believe that a
lot of times you're working hard but I
know plenty of people that come in it's
just like in jiu-jitsu this point if you
limit training for 15 years it frankly
suck and there's plenty of people that
have been training for four that are
pretty dang good you know for real and
again are they the best person that's
been training for four years is still
compared to like Kareena not that good
but they could be really really really
good because they understand how to be
directed and how to focus and I believe
this is something I've discussed you
know before with some other you know
friends of mine you know that some of
whom were at a very high level may
others that are the high level of
jiu-jitsu wrestling or whatever um look
at guys like Randy Couture guys a Rick
Hawn they're on their second career they
started MMA when they were like 32 and
yet they got to the top maybe they
weren't always champion but they were
fricking good why because they're 26
year old self would be scary but you
know like hey um they know what it is to
be dedicated and work hard and because
again they're Olympians like you said on
a level that a regular person has no
concept of so I think that that is
ultimately the skill it's not the oh man
this person's dangerous because he's got
good judo or good wrestling no this
person is dangerous because he or she
knows how to work their ass off and be
focused on a level that most people
can't comprehend and that's what
produces success in any area of life in
might hit you yeah be brutally honest
with yourself at all times and it stings
sometimes you know I think yeah it's
like the price of of looking inward you
know objectively is that you're not
going to like what you see a lot you
know and because even if you're like oh
man I'm 90% the way I want to be it's
like that if you are going to take that
next step in my opinion it's you're
going to focus on the 10% because it's
like oh man we're doing a lot of things
good yeah who gives a [ __ ] let's talk
about what we need to improve on you
know and that's a little bit less fun
but in the long run I think it's what's
it's what's going to drive you to a
higher level but at the same time I
think it's what makes a lot of people
that are like that a little bit neurotic
and nutty by compared by a normal
standard
right but again you show me someone
that's super well adjusted and I'll show
you someone that's probably not a high
achiever
you